what is it gary my son is leaving for
school
today lucas yeah you tell him to stay
home there with you
he won't you want me to talk to him yeah
but you won't change his mind
i'll change his mind
let me ruin college for him oh look at
gary's walking
yeah he's blocking with his new knee
yeah here's lucas de la batte
wow look how big lucas got i was a
little kid look at you you look like a
man now
listen lucas i'm going to talk straight
with you okay you shouldn't go to
college
you should do it all online why are you
going to risk your life
um yeah we don't think it's going to
last very long but
uh what we're planning on doing is just
doing online from home
up in syracuse and uh yeah just
you know spend time with friends in our
small bubble and
you know be responsible let me tell you
something these kids
they don't know what they're doing
they're going to get you sick
we can't risk that is it too tough to
stay home
i mean i i i like gary you could you
could put up with you know your dad
you could put up with him yes actually i
i was talking to him about that uh just
yesterday is like
like him my mom and uh jackson like
they're just a very easy family to live
at home with so
um definitely a little bit melancholy
about going back even though i'm a
junior
i didn't want to tell you this i'm your
real father believe me
yeah you knew it right you knew it in
your heart well that's where the height
comes from
that's where the height comes from you
you knew it you knew it but no you know
you've been looking down on your dad for
how long
and and the thing is son you must
protect yourself
if it gets too dicey up there come home
yeah yeah no i'll come back and uh you
know i'll stay with my mom and dad
by the way robin is your real mother i
didn't want to tell you about it
oh wow you know i knew when that sorry
we gave you away
that's right and it was like when that
dna test came back i knew there was
something going on
they taught you about contraception yes
yeah you know all about that you want me
to give you a little lecture on that
you're gonna have the talk with him
condom is the safest that's all i'm
saying
all right well anyway thank you if you
ever wanna if you have a question about
covet or girls you call me you're right
i'll step in
and i could see you're getting very
little advice all right thank you
guys stay safe good to see you lucas
you'd be safe stay home thank you that's
all i'm saying
boy gary he's lovely he said something
to me yesterday that
literally almost made me cry what are
you saying he said you know dad i really
appreciate
like your mom you know grandma was like
she had like a lot of issues
and you could have unloaded all that
[ __ ] on me and jackson
and you chose to not do that and to go a
different way and it goes i can't tell
you how much i appreciate that
wow that's nice
[Music]
gary you raised a beautiful sun
and gary you now have a new knee a
titanium knee
you love your family and chocolate
there goes your knee just fell out we'll
put it back